you
in our morning rounds the disturbing
surge and bug borne illnesses a new CDC
report finds the number of people who
get sick from mosquito tick and flea
bites is spreading rapidly the annual
total more than tripled between 2004 and
2016 in all more than 640,000 cases were
reported over that period nine new
diseases spread by insects including
Zika and chikungunya were reported for
the first time in the u.s. our Tara
Narula is here with more on this Tara
good morning good morning
the CDC tracked 16 diseases read from
bug bites why are we seeing the surge
right so there are a lot of reasons that
the CDC suggested but what we do know is
that these cases are increasing from
about 27,000 and 2004 annually to about
90,000 annually in 2016 so some of the
reasons they suggest more globalization
so there's increased travel these
diseases are as they said a plane flight
away there's trade of goods there's
people moving back and forth that
spreads disease
there's also climate change that plays
into it so the warmer the temperatures
the more the ticks can live in northern
climates that they normally couldn't
live in before and also the tick season
is longer in addition with the warmer
temperatures mosquitoes are more
infectious and the infections move
faster in addition to that we're testing
more now so we're picking up the
disease's there's urbanization
deforestation reforestation all of that
plays into it increased number of deers
because we don't hunt as often and also
more rodents because foxes and the
Predators aren't around as much good
when we hear the number 9 new diseases
that sounds like a lot and it sounds
like something we should be very
concerned about should we well not
necessarily I mean we should be
concerned and this is something that we
need to invest in which is dealing with
these vector borne diseases but two of
them you've heard of chikungunya and
Zika they're not necessarily new but
they're new to us in this country the
other ones were 7s tick borne diseases
some of which were bacterial and some of
which were viral so what do we do I know
whenever we get puddles after a big rain
you get those out of the way so that
mosquitoes don't live in there what
other kinds of kenton things can you do
right so removing standing water very
important also use
EPA recommended repellents as well as
permethrin treated clothing treat your
gear with permethrin check your animals
check yourselves and your family members
for ticks these are some of the
lifestyle things that you can do to kind
of help wear long sleeve shirts and
pants as uncomfortable as that might be
when you're out in the woods yes in the
summertime it is 87 degrees but all of
that getting chikungunya well right
exactly I'm glad we're glad we know what
to do thanks dr. Narula